A VERY POTENT MESSAGE TO
DEMOCRATS WITH THAT DECISION.
JAKE.
>> KYUNG LAH IN LAS VEGAS, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
>> TO SOUTH CAROLINA NOW WHERE
TWO REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE FIGHTING TO KEEP
THEIR JOBS IN PRIMARIES AFTER
DARING TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
CONGRESSWOMAN NANCY MACE
CRITICIZED TRUMP IN THE WAKE OF
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
TOM RICE WENT SO FAR AS TO VOTE
TO IMPEACH TRUMP.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS NOW
SEEKING REVENGE BY BACKING BOTH
OF THEIR REPUBLICAN CHALLENGERS
IN TUESDAY'S PRIMARY RACE.
JEFF ZELENY JOINS US NOW LIVE
FROM CHARLESTON, SOUTH CAROLINA.
YOU WERE WITH CONGRESSWOMAN MACE
WHILE SHE WAS CAMPAIGNING THIS
WEEKEND.
HOW DOES SHE SEEM?
IS SHE WORRIED?
>> JAKE, THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
SHE KNOS SHE'S IN A TOUGH
COMPETITION, CERTAINLY GIVEN THE
ENVIRONMENT, CERTAINLY THE
JANUARY 6th HEARING HAVE REVIVED
ALL OF THE FEELINGS OF JANUARY
6th, SO AMONG REPUBLICANS, THAT
COULD CERTAINLY PLAY A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS.
SHE DOES ALSO BELIEVE THAT SHE
HAS THE ARGUMENT THAT SHE WON
THIS DISTRICT AND SHE WON IT
BACK FROM DEMOCRATIC HANDS, SO
SHE BELIEVES SHE HAS A NARROW
UPPER HAND, BUT WHEN WE ASKED
HER IF SHE HAS ANY REGRETS OVER
CERTIFYING THAT ELECTION IN
2020, SHE SAID NO, BUT SHE DID
NOT MENTION TRUMP IN HER ANSWER.
>> I'M A CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSERVATIVE AND VOTED WITH
VOKES LIKE RAPD PAUL AND MIKE
LEE AND TIM SCOTT TO PRESERVE
THE CONSTITUTION.
WHAT WE COULDN'T DO IS ALLOW ONE
PERSON, THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, TO
SINGLE-HANDEDLY OVERTURN THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE IN THE RESULTS
OF A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
BECAUSE THEN YOU'RE SETTING THE
PRECEDENT THAT KAMALA HARRIS CAN
DO THAT IN 2024.
>> CALLING HERSELF A
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSERVATIVE.
ALSO CAMPAIGNING AT THE SITE OF
NIKKI HALEY, A FORMER POPULAR
GOVERNOR HERE WHO IS A MEMBER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CABINET.
>> YOU SPOKE WITH TOM RICE, WHO
IS FIGHTING OFF A CHALLENGE FROM
HIS MAGA RIGHT, HOW HAS HIS VOTE
TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP
PLAYED A ROLE IN HIS CAMPAIGN?
>> LOOK, JAKE, HE'S ONE OF TEN
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE WHO
VOTED TO IMPEACH.
MOST ARE NOT RUNNING AGAIN.
HIS DISTRICT IS JUST A BIT NORTH
HERE IN CHARLESTON.
WE CAUGHT UP WITH HIM.
MOST VOTERS WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
INFLATION.
BUT ONE VOTER SAID HE
CONGRATULATED HIM FOR DOING THE
BRAVE DECISION, FOR CASTING THAT
IMPEACHMENT VOTE.
I ASKED THE CONGRESSMAN ABOUT
THAT VOTE THAT STILL HANGS OVER
HIS HEAD.
>> I DON'T THINK IT WILL COST ME
MY ELECTION, CERTAINLY I HOPE IT
DOESN'T.
BUT DOING THE RIGHT THING COSTS
ME AN ELECTION, I'LL WEAR IT
LIKE A BADGE.
>> SO HE CALLS IT A BADGE OF
HONOR.
HE'S IN A MUCH MORE COMPETITIVE
RACE THAN NANCY MACE.
HE'S RUNNING AGAINST RUSSELL
FRY, ALSO BACKED BY FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT RACE IS LIKELY TO GO INTO A
RUN-OFF ELECTION DAY HERE
TOMORROW IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> JEFF ZELENY REPORTING LIVE
FROM CHARLESTON, SOUTH CAROLINA.
THANKS SO MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH MY PANEL.
DAVID URBAN, THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS GETTING PRIMARIED BY
PEOPLE IN THE MAGA RIGHT WHO SAY
THEY'RE NOT LOYAL ENOUGH TO
DONALD TRUMP.
AND YOU KNOW, YOU SEE
CONGRESSMAN RICE DIRECTLY DEFIED
TRUMP.
HOW FAR IS TRUMP WILLING TO GO
TO GET THESE NON-LOYAL
REPUBLICANS WHO MIGHT BE GREAT
LAWMAKERS OUT OF THE PARTY?
>> YOU SEE HE'S WILLING TO GO
ALL THE WAY.
SO YOU MAY END UP LOSING THE
SEAT.
AND THAT'S THE PART THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
NANCY MACE IS, YOU KNOW, I THINK
SHE'S AN R-PLUS 1 DISTRICT OR A
D-PLUS 2 DISTRICT.
>> THE WOMAN CHALLENGING HER
LOST A SEAT TO A DEMOCRAT.
>> THESE ARE INCREDIBLY TOUGH
RACES.
THE BRIAN FITZPATRICK SEAT IN
PENNSYLVANIA, THESE SEATS, IF
THEY'RE NOT HELD BY THESE PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO FLIP TO DEMOCRATIC
SEATS.
SO IF THE REPUBLICANS IN THEIR
ZEAL FOR BEING MAGA FIRST ABOVE
ALL, WANT TO RUN THAT DIRECTION,
WE'RE GOING TO RUN RIGHT OFF A
CLIFF.
>> NIA-MALIKA HENDERSON, THIS
WEEKEND YOU HEARD FORMER SOUTH
CAROLINA GOVERNOR AND U.N.
AMBASSADOR NIKKI HALEY STUMPING
FOR NANCY MACE IN HER HOME
STATE.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO THIS
MOMENT FROM THE CAMPAIGN.
>> TUESDAY IS ELECTION DAY, AND
I LOVE ELECTION DAY, ESPECIALLY
WHEN I'M NOT IN IT.
THANK YOU, AND GOD BLESS.
>> COME SOME CHEERS THERE FOR
PRESIDENT HALEY.
SHE IS SOMEBODY THAT SOME
REPUBLICANS HOPE RUNS FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2024.
>> YEAH, AND LINSE, SHE IS NOT
ONLY ACTIVE IN THIS CAMPAIGN IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
SHE'S BEEN IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, IN
IOWA.
SHE'S THIS UNIQUE POLITICIAN.
SHE AT ONE POINT WAS ONE OF THE
MOST POPULAR POLITICIANS IN THE
COUNTRY, HAVING AN APPROVAL
RATING OF 63%.
IT'S BECAUSE SHE REALLY WAS ABLE
TO THREAD THIS LINE OF BEING IN
TRUMP'S WORLD BUT NOT A
TRUMPIST.
AND YOU SAW SOME OF THAT AFTER
JANUARY 6th.
SHE SAID THAT DONALD TRUMP NEVER
HAD A FUTURE IN POLITICS, THAT
HE HAD FALLEN SO FAR IN TERMS OF
HIS LEGACY AND HISTORY WOULD
JUDGE HIM HARSHLY.
SHE THEN REGRETTED THAT AND
TRIED TO GO DOWN TO MAR-A-LAGO,
AND DONALD TRUMP SAID ABSOLUTELY
NOT.
AND THEN SHE SAID THAT SHE
WOULDN'T RUN IN 2024 IF DONALD
TRUMP RAN.
I THINK SOME POSSIBLE 2024
REPUBLICANS ARE LOOKING AT THIS
WEEK, RIGHT, ALL OF THE HEARI
TO LISTEN HOW STRONG IS DONALD
TRUMP GOING FORWARD IN 2024.
COULD YOU IF YOU'RE NIKKI HALEY
CREDIBLY MAKE A RUN FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I THINK HER PROBLEM IS WHAT IS
HER LANE?
IS SHE THE EVANGELICAL CHOICE,
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE CHOICE?
SHE'S NOT REALLY A TRUMPIST.
SHE'S NOT IN OFFICE IN THE WAY
THAT RON DeSANTIS IS OR GREG
ABBOTT WHO HAVE STRONGER CASES
TO MAKE TO THE TRUMP BRAND, BUT
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE.
>> I'LL GO FARTHER THAN THAT AND
SAY A BUNCH OF REPUBLICANS
THINKING OF RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2024 ARE HOPING
THAT IT'S DEVASTATING FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE -- I
THINK THERE ARE A BUNCH OF THEM
WHO WANT IT BE AS BAD AS
POSSIBLE FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> I THINK SO BECAUSE THEY NEED
HIM OUT OF THE WAY IF THEY'RE
DOING TO HAVE THEIR OWN
POLITICAL FUTURE.
HE'S TIED THEM UP IN KNOTS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
WHAT YOU SHOWED THERE WITH NIKKI
HALEY ON STAGE WITH NANCY MACE,
I MEAN, THE INVISIBLE PRIMARY
ALWAYS STARTS EARLY.
IT'S ALREADY GOING ON, AND THE
SUBTEXT OF ALL OF THESE
CANDIDATES TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO PRESSURE DONALD TRUMP
TO GO AGAINST DONALD TRUMP
WITHOUT SAYING THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
I MEAN, SHE'S STANDING ON A
STAGE NEXT TO A CANDIDATE HE'S
TRYING TO TAKE OUT.
IT'S A DIRECT CONFRONTATION TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
BUT AS NIA WAS OUTLINING, IT'S A
TRICKY PLACE FOR ANYONE TO BE
RIGHT NOW, SO I THINK TO YOUR
POINT, IF THESE HEARINGS THIS
WEEK ARE WHAT ULTIMATELY TAKES
TRUMP OUT OF THE PARTY, I
REMEMBER AFTER JANUARY 6th,
OBVIOUSLY, IT WAS A DEVASTATING
DAY, BUT THERE WERE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WHO WERE EAGER TO